we start with really grim news because
we've reached a grim milestone in the
spread of the corona virus in the US the
nationwide death toll has now topped a
thousand people news nobody wants to
hear today there are more than 69,000
reported cases across the country
nowhere has been harder hit than right
here in the New York metro area one
hospital in Elmhurst Queens had 13
fatalities in just 24 hours our lead
national correspondent David Beck know
has a look inside that hospital David
good morning that's a lot of dead people
in just a 24-hour period how are they
coping there well Toni they're doing
everything they can but it is sobering
to hear what you are about to hear if
New York is the epicenter of the
coronavirus crisis in the u.s. Elmhurst
Hospital is really the epicenter within
the epicenter you're about to hear from
an emergency room doctor who sent a
video and an interview to the New York
Times and essentially said I don't care
if I get in trouble for talking to the
media because the world needs to know
what we are dealing with in here the
support that I need and even just the
materials that I need physically to take
care of my patients that's dr. Colleen
Smith she gave the New York Times a look
inside Elmhurst emergency room
you see they all have today is kind of
getting worse and worse we had to get a
refrigerated truck to store the bodies
of patients who are dying the
frustrating thing about all of this is
it really just feels like it's too
little too late like we knew we knew
what was coming dr. Smith says they have
been scrambling to get more ventilators
these few were this week's third
resupply unless people died I suspect
we'll be back to needing to beg for
ventilators again in another day or two
the head of New York's public hospital
system claims that Elmhurst has never
come even close to running out of
ventilators he says getting supplies and
personnel to its hospitals is the
system's number-one priority FEMA says
the federal government delivered 2,000
ventilators to New York yesterday but
the governor of New York says he needs
thousands more
we need 30,000 we have in the existing
hospital system 4,000 ventilators the
governor continues to ask people for
mandatory social distancing and he says
it might be working rates of
hospitalizations have actually slowed
this week this is a very good sign and a
positive sign in nearby New Jersey
medical personnel and protective gear
evacuated nearly 80 people living at a
Woodbridge nursing home after 11 people
inside the building tested positive for
kovat 19 back in New York the governor
is preparing for things to get worse a
makeshift morgue has been built to house
the bodies of those who died years
things like we're gonna be fine
everything's fine and from our
perspective everything is not fine the
governor of New York has been asking
hotels here in New York City to open
their doors to medical personnel who are
battling the virus and the Four Seasons
is in depth an example of one hotel that
said listen come in we will house you
guys for free I want you to know that
New York's governor says social
distancing is working to the point where
they're working on a plan to close
streets in New York City and open them
up to pedestrians so that people can get
out get some air but maintain that
social distance oh boy David people do
need some air that's some good news
something hopeful to look forward to we
thank you for that we want to get some
more from our dr. David agus who joins
us from his home in Los Angeles he's
gonna shed some light on why things have
become so dire here in New York City dr.
agus good morning we just saw an image
of a refrigerated 18-wheeler to deal
with the bodies a makeshift morgue in
preparation of bodies elsewhere but New
York is a unique situation it's a big
city we're packed on top of each other
why do you call it a perfect storm well
you've got the subway you've got the
streets where people literally have to
before this happen had to walk right arm
and arm next to each other and so for a
virus that's the perfect place it can
spread host to host to host you breathe
someone walks by you breathe in those
droplets and it really was you know
perfect places to spread in addition
it's one of the most international
cities people were flying in from
everywhere in the world including areas
that were heavily affected like China
and they would come and they would
spread the virus and obviously we're
seeing the ramifications of that several
weeks later you know it was chilling
David to hear from the doctor and the
tape who said look I know I'm probably
going to get in trouble for telling you
the story but people need to know what
is happening here I applaud her her
bravery for really taking us behind the
scenes I'm wondering your thoughts on
that because I know you two are hearing
from doctors who are on the front lines
no I mean you get emotional nurses who
are positive or told to come in in that
Hospital and then we're in garbage bags
as protective material because there are
no more gowns to wear and when you hear
that in our country today it's just
horrible we
to be able to distribute resources
better there are hospitals across the
country that have protective gear this
hospital is out of it and it's at the
epicenter now I'm going to calls from
doctors literally you know every hour
saying I'm afraid I can't go home and
that's why I love the fact the Four
Seasons stepping up and saying here's a
place for you guys to live so you don't
infect your families it just breaks your
heart when you hear these stories
obviously of the patients and of the
caregivers yeah at these hospitals who
are risking their lives daily to try to
help people what did you just say that
nurses who have tested positive or asked
to come to work even though they're
testing positive how can that be helpful
yeah it's just I mean they're taking
care of patients who are positive I
guess the hospital argues and it was
confirmed last night that nurses were
testing positive or actually has to come
in and care for patients and to wear
protective gear which is third world
this is this is a war zone and what
people don't understand when they talk
about this if you walk through the wards
of the hospital there are patients lying
dirty talk about privacy there's no
curtain they're just patients lying on
gurney gurney gurney you know people you
know everywhere I'm just waiting for the
hope that they can be seen you know when
someone is sick and admitted to a
hospital it's a 7 to 10 to 14 days stay
and so once a bed is occupied that bed
is occupied for weeks then you have to
figure out another bed and another bed
and once you start to reach critical
mass patients just pile up we haven't
figured out a better way of dealing with
these epi Center places with resources I
know and I know people are always trying
to figure this out thank you very much
David